the slogan that sex is liberatory has
really just been sold to you by durx
let's be
[Music]
honest should commitment and monogamy
hold the moral High Ground now Stephen
I'm going to come to you first yeah so
I've done a political commentary for
quite a while online and I'm currently
in a marriage with my wife and we have
an open marriage so in basically every
single conversation I have I get a lot
of questions related to the structure of
our relation reltionship and the
questions are generally paired with a
lot of judgment as well I would say that
if we look at the way that Society is
shaped today we look at the successes or
failures of monogamous relationships at
least in the United States feels like
there's a lot of pressure on monogamous
relationships that people haven't been
able to adapt to so for instance um I
think in the United States almost half
of our marriages and a divorce I think
if you do polling anywhere from 10 to
25% of people report on cheating on a
spouse so it seems like there is a lot
of pressure to be monogamous but not
everybody seems to work well within the
these types of relationships I think
that when you look for alternative ways
to live a lifestyle I think it's
important to understand why you want to
live in a different way I know there's a
uh sometimes uh it could be tempting to
change things just for the sake of
changing things or changing things to
Rebel but I wish that in society we
could have more open and Frank
conversations about the types of
relationships we have rather than just
assuming that there is one style of
relationship that has to be the default
good style and everything that doesn't
fall within that window is you know
receiving the IR and harsh Judgment of
everybody around so I would say no I
don't believe that monogamous
relationships ought to have the moral on
High Ground as long as people are open
and honest and they're communicating
well within their relationships and
everybody's a consenting member I think
that those types of relationships should
be able to be exploited by people as
well you know I know this discussion is
geared around the idea that something
self sort of emancipatory about sex with
multiple people is somehow going to
create the basis for personal Liberation
but I'm sorry to tell you that personal
Liberation a lot more complex than that
and coming from a tradition where I
think Liberation is much more tied to
the idea that actually you can find
Freedom from choosing your constraints
rather than the idea that freedom is the
complete absence of constraints um so as
such I don't see sex or any act uh
outside of the meaning that it has
within the collective or within the
power relations which come to Define it
and I always look at who benefits the
most from any situation in which we
change the standards that's existed in
society marriage has certainly not
served women in many ways historically
but the absence of marriage hm let's
talk there's this really weird world we
live in where I have a feeling that it
feels like when we talk about sex
especially we talk about literally
everything beside sex um all he like
sociopolitical analysis I'll hear
feminist analyses um I hear a lot of
talk about not raping people uh but we
never actually talk about like what
healthy relationships or healthy sexual
relationships look like and I guess I
wish sometimes the conversation I
understand that there's a need sometimes
to look at things through the uh look at
things through the lens of kind of like
social analyses or class structure or
whatever but I wish sometimes we would
just focus more on like the actual
nitty-gritty of like what is a positive
sexual encounter or what does a positive
relationship look like or what does sex
look like in a relationship so that
people would kind of have more tools to
build on to work on relationships uh
like for instance I feel like sometimes
you come out of certain talks where
people talk about the relationships
between men and women and you feel
horrible and then you have like nothing
you can do about it like you go home and
it's Bally I guess like well the world
is basically I'm part of an
oppressive structure and there's
literally nothing I can do besides
continuing to traumatize myself with the
sexual interactions I have with people
around me and yeah I don't know I guess
sometimes it'd be like you know like
here's how to make sure your partner is
having a good time or here's something
to keep in mind to make sure that you're
having a fulfilling experience for both
of you and I feel like that's like
relegated to just sex blogs or Playboy
and we never have like real mature adult
conversations about it in a wider
Society one of the questions that we
talked about was this idea that um the
decline in marriage and the increasing
open relationships is somehow a sign of
a deteriorating culture or of a
liberated one and I just wanted to point
out that you know you your question
around like do we look at sex in
long-term relationships and there are
studies on this you know actually people
in longer term relationships do report
being more sexually satisfied than
people who were single you know single
hookups on you know social apps are
rarely what they're built up to be I
mean the uh you know the slogan that sex
is liberatory has really just been sold
to you by durx let's be honest long-term
relationships are also a really
um important way of getting to know
yourself it's one of the only Arenas
where somebody holds a mirror up to you
long term about what kind of a douche
you actually are and if you don't have
that because every time somebody lifts
the mirror up to you you cut the cord
and you dip then we have a problem you
will just remain the that you
were when you enter the relationship I
feel like I know a lot of people in Long
monogamous relationships that are still
douchebags I feel like the idea that
marriage works is like the ultimate
therapy to fix a person's problems uh is
it doesn't necessarily hold true it
could for some people but the caricature
of polyamory will always suffer to the
ideal that is monogamy but I mean the
ideal of monogamy doesn't exist anywhere
you know it's funny I'll have people
tell me like how can you handle you or
your partner being another person and
it's like there are monogamous people
that can't handle their partner having a
female coworker right or there are
people that can't handle their partner
uh talking to people that they used to
date or having friends of the opposite
sex um I feel like things like jealousy
or irritation with our partners or
reflection with our partners these
things can manifest in so many different
ways in so many different relationships
there are things that I've learned from
my wife that I could have probably never
learned from any other person there are
things that I've learned being a father
to my son there are things that I've
learned from friends from co-workers
from peers in my industry um I think
that life and relationships are often
times what you make it I think that you
can find Value in monogamous
relationships arguably even Special
Value that maybe you wouldn't have
gotten otherwise if you're the type of
person that's built for it but I think
there is a special type of harm caused
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left in the
description below or visit I a.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas